how would you have handled the
leadership role in the first world war
trench in the trenches in other words
seemingly
helpless situation this is this is a
question that i didn't even
want to answer because it's just such a
brutal question
and that's why i did answer it because i
i want to have some brutal questions and
i would love to
think that i would have stood up like a
man and like a hero and done
everything in my power to stop
the madness and to come up with a new
way and protest the futile tactics and
raise my hand and say we're not doing
this sir i will not
send my men to their deaths i would
love to think that that's what i would
have done
and i can tell you when when when i was
told to do things in iraq that
i thought we shouldn't be doing i said
hey you know what that's not a good idea
let's find another way let's do
something different so i know i've done
that before we got we got
we had operations that we looked at and
said you know what
this is not a smart operation there's a
really high risk and there's very low
reward
let's let's let's not do that one let's
find another way to do it so i know i've
done that
but you take me and you put me in a
world war one trench now we have a
different mind
i have a different brain and the thing
that i'm scared of the thing that
haunts me is what if my mind was
trapped
what if i couldn't see the futility of
the situation
because everyone's saying no you know
what when we do this attack
we've done these things and we've
prepared for it and we've got more bombs
we're going to drop we've got more
artillery
this is going to be the one
you just need to go over the top one
more time what if i believe that
what if i couldn't see the solutions
in front of me and that's what scares me
is
what if you become
so brainwashed and close-minded that you
cannot see anymore and you lose your
ability to
think and that's why
all the time you're gonna hear me say
free
your mind that's what i'm talking about
for your mind
that is the situation that i am talking
about
question what is around you question the
status quo
and question the authority and the
leadership and
your subordinates question everything
in order to make sure that you're not
following a a well-worn
path a well-worn
path that other people have gone
by maybe it's a path that you've walked
before
but it's a well-worn path and it's a
path
that leads to suffering and pain
and tragedy and you can't get off the
path because your mind
is not free
so how would i have handled the
leadership
situation in world war one i cannot
honestly answer that question
but the way i try and live and the way
i try and think
is one with an open mind a free mind
that can see that can see different
perspectives
that can detach from what's being told
to me
and i can question it and i can come up
with a different solution
free your mind
sound advice it's a tough question